Polls show that 95% of men and 72% of women have taken their lives. But
With rumors circulating that he is unhealthy, can cause blindness, even infertility, can masturbation
To be useful to you? Feel yourself not only for single people. 70% of men and 40% of women
In intimate relationships they mentioned masturbation in the last four weeks before the survey.
In the end, he feels good. It not only produces dopamine, which helps control
Reward centers and pleasure in the brain, reduce feelings of tension, but other chemicals are released during
Orgasm can reduce your sense of pain. For women masturbation can reduce the cramp
Menstruation. Of course, with the help of prolactin, which is associated with sleep,
You may feel tired and need to sleep. Do you feel like you are infected?
Cold? One study found that in males, components of the immune system
Activates during masturbation, causing an increase in the number of white blood cells in the bloodstream.
Individual sessions can also help men reduce their risk of cancer, frequent high ejaculation speed has been linked
With a lower risk of exposure to total prostate cancer. Although it is unclear why, researchers assume
Increased repeated ejaculation means possible carcinogenic secretions in the prostate
It excretes more regularly, reducing the negative effect on the body. but why
Evolution of humans and animals to masturbation if it appears to be a waste of energy or semen
In men? Well, it turns out that self-love (masturbation) can improve the quality of sperm.
A recent study showed that male masturbation reduces the number of fertilized sperm in
The next intercourse, but not the number of sperm retained by females. From this, he concluded
Masturbation is a masculine strategy to improve the fitness of their sperm and smaller sperm
Have a higher probability of inoculation. Not only that but masturbation can improve
Your sexual performance. Both women and men have the muscles of the pelvic floor that extend from the
The pubic bone you have to the bone of your coccyx. As we get older, these muscles weaken, causing sexual impotence
In women and erectile dysfunction in men. But the penile penis or clitoris can be activated
The cavernous cavernous reflex, leading to contraction of the pelvic floor muscles. Masturbation is basically
Exercise for your sexual muscles. Nitric oxide levels also decrease with age and can contribute
In low sexual arousal but masturbation can help keep it in the bloodstream throughout
Your life. But while masturbation has physiological benefits, it is important
To confuse Asalbeck. Use the same download method every time it can make you
Do not respond to other types of sexual stimulation. This can lead to decreased libido,
Or performance when it comes time to do sexual work with your real partner. So make sure
From the mix of Asalbek! At the end of the day, masturbation activity is safe and healthy, so place
Some of the music, lit up those candles, and feasted on a good night. And if you really love
Flag, we have a new shirt for sale for another one week, but unlike most things traded, science
Logical and unforgettable, and these shirts of science will never end their subject. seriously.
Science never comes out of fashion. Click on the screen, or use the link in the description
For one. Do not forget to publish this video on Facebook and Twitter and subscribe to the channel
More weekly scientific videos! Translation: عبدالرحمن